en este vídeo te voy a decir formas
distintas de ganar dinero que puedes
hacer con cualquier edad desde cualquier
parte del mundo y sin ningún tipo de
inversión inicial la primera forma de
ganar dinero siendo adolescente consiste
en utilizar shooterstock a tienen todo
tipo de imágenes por ejemplo aquí pues
perros lo buscamos y Tenemos un montón
de imágenes de todo tipo Entonces
nosotros lo que podemos hacer es vender
estas imágenes cómo hacemos esto pues
simplemente bajamos hasta abajo del todo
y hacemos clic aquí donde pone venda Su
contenido hacemos clic y por aquí nos
aparece toda la información la siguiente
forma de ganar dinero siendo adolescente
es utilizando Robert Robert es una
página web que lo que hace es poner en
contacto a personas que tienen perros o
gatos y a personas que están dispuestas
a cuidar de estos perros o gatos La
última forma de ganar dinero siendo
adolescente es utilizando Toluca tocas
una página web gratuita en la cual vamos
a hacer varias tareas y nos van a pagar
por ello Es bastante sencillo utilizar
aquí tenemos toda la información aquí
nos Aparecen las tareas y Bueno pues hay
varios tipos de tareas algunas
relacionadas con imágenes o vídeos texto
audio Bueno pues hay varios tipos de
tareas y algo que me gustaría recalcar
es que si Nosotros sabemos hablar
correctamente inglés nos van a aparecer
más tareas y por lo tanto vamos a ganar
más